protect your son what happened we merge
we come together I think for each others
teachers but but yeah she's taught me a
lot
Mariska Hargitay and Olivia Benson are
one in the same
the actress opened up to et at the
Tribeca TV festival about celebrating
the 20th anniversary of Law & Order
Special Victims Unit if you ask me 20
years ago I never thought I would be
here 20 years later but I am and I am
fulfilled and I love my co-stars and I
am in this incredible collaboration with
producers and with the writers so I'm
really enjoying it I'm just trying to be
President present and very and grateful
so I'm thinking about this year about
this season and how to make it the best
and then thinking a little bit about
next year you know my first memories are
the auditions which I remember like they
were yesterday meeting press and meeting
dick and reading predict and having that
experience and pretty and sort of having
the character get in at the audition
that the network raver someone's gunning
for huh
or us either way this comes out his
objectivity gets called into question
and triggers a mistrial incredibly
blessed you know it's been an incredible
privilege and it's fun because I guess
the penny keeps dropping now with
moments like this you're sort of forced
to to really take it in because I feel
like I've been in this marathon for 20
years you know just doing the work every
day our days are long and it's really a
marathon so it's sort of beautiful to
have these moments to celebrate
[Music]
[Applause]